being an astronaut preparing to go to
space zoom do you have to prepare to be
an astronaut to go to space so you are
to do all this stuff in the film like
that weird whirligig thing there
multi-axis trainer that looks horrible
yeah I don't remember much I just
remember the directors saying more
spinning the rest is kind of a blank
because are you just in it or do you
control it in some way no you don't
control oh can you just eat it yeah
feeling did you get sick a lot wow it
was very hard to complain because the
director went through such lengths to
make sure this was authentic I mean
incredible amount of detail into making
these capsules you know almost exactly
as they were and we had you know
technicians who were involved in these
missions on set every day and any time
you thought about complaining you you
know you would go to the monitor and
somebody you know some astronaut you
would say well you know Ryan when I went
to the moon just keep talking and you
slowly forget about what it was that was
bothering you but you decided you were
garden to learn how to fly because you
know I'm strong enough playing that's
right
yeah how did that go you know Neil could
fly before he could drive he he grew up
watching planes as a kid so he could pay
for lessons and flight was just you know
I'm so important to him so I thought oh
I'll learn how to fly and you know you
always hear about celebrities flying and
I was like how hard could it be well
it's very hard it's very hard and pretty
quickly into my training my flight
instructor told me to take the plane
into a self-imposed all it's just you
you stall it on purpose and I just
thought this is a terrible idea
land right away and I'll spend my time
learning other things
[Applause]
[Music]
you